hey there Akuma fans Charlie with the
got secure application staff thought
today we might do a little video talking
about advanced OneTouch software for the
turning centers on Akuma today we're
working on an LV 3000 my W and the topic
that keeps coming up is milling C axis
versus Y axis milling and so what I
thought we would do today is to I'll
make a simple bolt this this bolt will
be about oh let's go 3.75 long and it'll
have a 1 in 3/8 head over here and I'm
not gonna bother with the threading at
this point we're just gonna turn the
shank on the main spindle then we'll
grab this part by the sub spindle move
it over and I'll show you about doing
some hex work a couple of options that
should help you out so the first thing
we have to do obviously is well I've
already defined my material but let's
take a look at it if I come over to my
blank set up right here you can see that
I'm using 1045 whatever it's a tool
steel I'm not gonna worry about feeds
and speeds right here so let's not let's
not hold Charlie's feet to the fire that
won't be cool so my I'm using inch and
5/8 stocks since I computed out the one
point three seven five bolt head we'll
have about one one point five eight ish
from point to point across the flats so
one sixty five stock will be just fine
and I'm gonna make it three seven fifty
long although the way I'm doing this is
I am anticipating using bar stock so I'm
gonna do a cut off process allow a bar
feed to advance my material and then
take the half-finished part over to the
sub spindle so that isn't really a true
a true number right there but I'm using
one three seventy-five that's the
finished oal of the part so that my
graphics will be a little easier to
understand for us there's no inside
diameter my base surface is on the right
end now I tell everybody when I'm when
I'm teaching them that this dimension
zero position for spindle number one
it's not really relevant to the program
regardless of what you put in here the
program is going to come out exactly the
same however if you want to see material
being removed in your graphics put a
negative value in here and that's how
much the äôt graphics the process
simulation is going to show the the
material coming off the face of the part
Mac spindle speed I set that not to the
Machine maximum but to the setup maximum
that's pretty much a given and then make
sure that you continue to scroll down if
you're doing a two spindle operation
because here we've got the dimensions
zero position for number two and make
that the oal of your part you notice as
soon as I click on it the graphic
changes and it shows me where the zero
point is when the parts being held in
the sub spindle
if you fail to populate that you're
going to find when you get down the road
that the misty software does not ask you
if you want to work on the left spindle
or the right spindle this is where it
decides that we're doing a full-blown lb
3000 my W style program so once I get
that all done I'm gonna say okay and now
we're working on our left spindle
although the machine is going to ask us
every time we start a new process which
spindle we're working on which is why it
gives us the the two datums here so by
touching the very first line in the
process sheet and by finding the word
process edit by touching it because this
row was blank it automatically decides
that okay we must be making a new
process so it asks us first off the bat
one spindle or two spindle now not to
beat a dead horse but if in my blank
setup I did not make a two spindle datum
it's gonna skip right over this page and
you'll never get the opportunity to work
on the second spindle so a lot of people
get a little confused by that hey what
happened to my two spindle option but
let's start by the one spindle and as
soon as I select one spindle here are
all the processes it knows how to make
and we're just gonna do a simple turning
on the OD this is gonna be a rough
because I want to take this down to
about oh let's just call this a 7/8
diameter usable length of the bolt and
now I will answer the question is this
an ID and OD back turn in our case this
is an OD and we're turning forward so
it's the primary selection I already
have tools registered here that's why
it's that it's saying hey alright what
register tool are you using it's
assuming it's registration number one
which is a CNM G I put that in my tool
data table and all I need to do is
select the tool number and offset number
that I'm using all the other data is
already computed from the register tool
as soon as I'm finished with this page
I'm going to follow along with my my
rule of thumb as I walk through AO T
which is if you're finished or you feel
you're finished with a page always look
for the word next don't look at what
follows next because that's just
informative the write down here at the
bottom I have the word next and in this
case the next page is cut condition but
I'm not worried about what comes next I
just need to know the word next will
advance me to the next option I'm not
going to sit here and dicker over fees
and speeds but my defaults are set
pretty well to where yep clockwise
spindle I want some coolant I want
constant cutter speed versus constant
spindle speed 460 seems about right for
this feed rate of 14 thousandths that's
cool cut depth 160 Wow way to go Charlie
you set all your defaults pretty well
and then my finish in X and Z so now I
am done with this page I'm gonna look
for the word next there it is
next is now we're gonna do the shape so
the shape of this bolt I want to start
below the OD of the shank of this bolt
and I want to do a little travel up make
an edge break and then continue on with
the shank so as I said earlier I want
this to be about a seven eighths
diameter shake so let's start with a
start point of X point six that'll work
for us yeah we're doing this an inch
today so I don't don't think it's a
point six millimeters here and start
point in Z is zero now before I March on
after this I want to specify that when
you were telling the a AO T software
about shapes they want to know at what
point is a tool going to contact
material a lot of times if I were
programming by hand I would start out
here off the part and so my start point
might be point six by 0.1 Oh T does not
want to know that they want to know when
is the tool going to touch material and
we'll deal with lead ins and lead outs
at a later process questionnaire so I'm
going to start at X six by Z zero and
the first move that I need to make is
going to be a an upward move which is
the face option and it wants to know
first off what speed do I want to go in
we're just gonna keep this all in rough
speed right now and where do I want to
end now as I mentioned I'm gonna go to
seven eighths diameter but I want to
throw a chamfer on there so that my
thread has a nice lead so I'm gonna use
the corner chamfering option now I don't
have a corner chamfering option right
here however because I know in my head
that that's what I want to do on this
first move I'm simply gonna say I want
you to go to the seven eighths diameter
yep there it's starting to draw it for
me right here but oh I wanted that sham
fur so now that I've got the destination
or the endpoint right here these two
options down on the soft keys will give
me an opportunity to either throw in a
radius or a chamfer so let's do a
chamfer and select a feed rate that's
better than rough and the Sham for size
so let's just put in like oh let's say
ninety thousandths look at that it
automatically said oh okay I understand
that your destination endpoint is X
point 875 but it automatically back
figured okay I got to travel in a linear
motion to 695 and then to make a 90
thousand Shaffer I'm gonna go to 875 the
next move is going to be calculated from
that point and the most logical solution
is to say hey I want a longitudinal move
or z axis only let's kick back up our
feed rate and you notice that X is
grayed out because it knows hey wait
this move is a z axis only so I'm going
to take whatever X I was delivered to in
the previous line and I'm gonna stay
there so let's make this about o let's
make this a good
Elfi bolt - 3.25 now you notice that I
made a little mistake here I started to
put in positive three point two five I'm
gonna go ahead and make that mistake
watch what happens to my line as soon as
I hit enter and okay it inverted my sham
fur and it's sent my Z all the way out
to positive this is a mistake I make all
the time and I glance over and say
whoops I forgot I can get back in here
and change it simply by making sure that
the erroneous move is highlighted arrow
over one time and now I've got a button
for edit so let's edit that we'll make
it minus three point two five and as
soon as I say okay
my graphic corrects itself Wow cool in
it now make sure you arrow back one two
more times so that I'm back to my
primary motion page now I'm ready to
travel up in X to the major diameter of
the hex that I plan on cutting on
spindle too so I'm gonna use this same
automatic corner sham frame to make a
little edge break on the underside of
this bolt so let's do a facing move and
we'll keep the feed rate at rough but
this time we'll go to that X 1.58
diameter that I mentioned goes straight
to the point there we go
and before we get there let's put on the
corner chamfer we'll make that a nice
finish and our shape for sighs let's do
about fifty thousands just to say we did
there it is boom so now we have shampoo
for the thread major for the thread face
on the underside of the bolt head a
little edge break so that the hex is
going to be nice and clean and now let's
just make one final move along the Z
let's make this head say Oh half-inch so
if I look at my previous three point two
five was the base before the shampoo so
let's take this two minus three point
seven five that'll be a half-inch there
and by the way if I wanted to I could
add a little bit for my part off tool
and I don't have to do the math in my
head or on a calculator I could say -
3.75 - point 135 because that is the
width of my part off blade then when I
hit enter it automatically does the math
for me how cool is that
boom so now I've taken the part or the
turning tool all the way down to the end
enough clearance for the part off not to
crash into something just because I like
to do so I'm going to take a final move
to the old diameter of the stock I do
that just because I don't like a rough
step on the bar behind us on the on the
next part so I always take it out to the
raw stock diameter now that I'm finished
I'll look for the word next that's right
here my tool path is the lead in and
lead out that I told you about just a
few minutes ago I've got my default set
up pretty well that's a whole nother
video that we'll go over at a later date
but I'll explain what these are briefly
the cycle reference point X and Z this
is where the machine is going to deliver
the tool when it calls the canned cycle
so there is a move that's 50 thousandths
greater than my bar stock diameter and
50,000 soph the face notice there's a
little red triangle right there that
looks pretty good to me that gives me an
opportunity to make sure that my tool
gauging is correct when the tool first
comes down to the part if I have single
block on while it's executing this line
I know it shouldn't touch material I
have one last chance to glance and say
that looks good
cut position outside yup it's it out
outside part that's good escape a
pattern do I want to go X then Z or do I
want to do both at the same time I'm not
worried about it so I'm gonna take a two
axis now the process
start and end points in X and Z allow me
to assign an intermediate point either
before the before the cut starts or
after the cut finishes for instance if
this were a boring bar and I wanted to
make sure that I pulled out of the hole
before going home
I could put a process endpoint in here
that's somewhere get below the final
bore size and out in front of the part
but in this case I'm good to go my tool
index position that's where it's going
to deliver the tool after the cut is
complete
somewhere far enough away so that I can
index the turret in my case default is
fine with 20 inches in X and 5 inches in
Z and the final is an escape position if
I were doing a repeating function let's
say it was a groove and I have three of
these grooves I want to have a an escape
point in between doing those grooves I
can apply that here but since I don't
need it I'm going to leave all of these
alone all my defaults look good there is
no more next button at this point
because this is the final page so I'm
just going to click on the word ok and
now I have a process let's take a look
at it
so I'm going to touch process test and
watch it bring me into my graphics now I
like this isometric viewpoint but when
you first fire up the software you are
probably going to see something akin to
that which is just fine but let's show
you how to manipulate this when you are
in your process test page by touching
display change now you have a whole
bunch of different options for how to
look at this part such as hey let's see
half of the part or let's turn it
transparent in my case what I want is an
angle
change and these little icons here will
show me exactly what I'm looking at and
really what I like is this this
isometric view right here gives me an
opportunity to see what's going on
once I've changed my viewpoint I must
return and then quit that quit is to get
out of display change not out of process
test so now I'm gonna hit the start
button let's watch what happens there
goes my turning tool do to do to do
there's my shampoo on top there's my
sham for in front everybody's happy now
just to just to keep myself clean and
level let's do a finishing pass with the
same tool just to say I did now you
notice that I made sure that I if I was
on the machine I would reach up and
touch the screen on the next process or
on äôt for the PC I just click on the
next operation the reason is if you have
the an operation highlighted and you do
process edit it simply opens up that
process as if you want to change
something but if you have touched the
next process a blank one and you touch
the process edit button it just says oh
okay we're ready to start a new one so
again this is a one spindle this is a
turning we're gonna do a finish
it's an OD and we have a registered tool
still in there using tool number one and
offset one go to next cut condition we
all look good now I'm gonna do the next
shape well doggone it I don't want to go
through all that stuff again so because
I did a roughing cycle I have an
opportunity down here to use shape copy
if I touch it it shows me all of the
processes well I only have one and there
is rough OD it knows that hey I did a
roughing cycle do you want to finish
that one yes I do touch it
say execute and it automatically
populates my current tool with the
geometry that was used in the previous
operation wow that made life easy so now
I'll just do my next tool path all those
are good say okay now I have a roughing
and a finishing
let's watch it still in that default
three-dimensional thing there's my
roughing and there's my finishing boom
okay now I've got a rough bolt head so
let's quit out of my process edit and
now we're ready to cut this thing off
and transfer it to the other side well
this is where we have to think two steps
ahead of what we want to do in in
practicality what we want to do is have
the sub spindle come over and grab the
part and then do a cut off a ot is going
to want to back figure things so the
first thing that it wants is a cut off
I'm gonna do the cut off first so
highlight a new process due process edit
this is on the one spindle we're still
turning and the cut off falls under the
groove category so let's grab the groove
and there is cut off won't it already
knows that I have a registered tool it's
tool number twelve I'll tell it it's
offset twelve tool number and then we'll
go next cut condition because this is a
cut off process it gives me a few
different options still have the spindle
in the coolant but I also have my
constant cutter speed and pecking if I
want to and let's leave it on for this
case just so that hey alright this is
some tool steel we'll see what happens
cutting speed I'm happy my feed rate my
cutting depth this is the amount that
the tool is going to cut in between
pecks that I specified here and then the
depth to retract is how far the tool is
going to cut pecking at this increment
before it pulls all the way out of the
hole and then rapids back into where
where it left off last so at 79
thousandths and 270,000 say that's fine
if I wanted it to do a short retract all
the way down I would simply tell it that
the depth retract would be greater than
the overall travel of the cut let's do
that I'm just gonna say hey my depth
retract is 2 inches well I'm not doing
to two full inches of travel so it's
going to short retract all the way to
the final cut off now the cut off
process has these last three options
that tend to throw people for a loop
they're like no of rot cut off what the
heck is that so this is a secondary feed
rate that we can do we can enact before
the tool gets all the way to x0 to
complete the cutoff so the number of
rotation cutoff is really asking for
hey what spindle speed do you want when
you get right down to the center of the
part so let's tell it oh hey I want to
do about 750 rpm when you get to the
bottom I'm gonna slow from my four
thousandths down to mm and my cutoff
diameter this is asking me when do you
want to enact this secondary feed rate
so we're gonna say 200,000 so that's
just fine so that way when the the tool
starts getting towards the center of the
part we can reduce some of the cutting
pressure next shape there we go okay so
now we have a little compass rose down
here that's showing us exactly what we
want the start point in a
for x-axis there's our a there's our
x-axis it wants to know where is that
cut start point I'm going to use the 1
5/8 diameter that I turned to awesome
now my a point for the z axis where is
that in Z here I'm gonna have to get a
little fancy because I do know that my
total part is minus three point seven
five is the overall of the part but I
also want to take out the minus one
point three fifty from the part off tool
because it's asking for that point not
that point now my depth oh shoot I don't
want to calculate that but I do know
where my bottom X is this guy down here
that should be at oh let's go - point
zero one so it goes all the way over
center line and as soon as I hit enter
it automatically calculated my depth for
me nice all of these other ones are
grayed out right now because I haven't
selected certain options for this cutoff
don't need to on this side I have two
fields that are lit up right now the
first is point a do you want to put some
kind of edge break on that well that's
bar stock I don't care about that
however point D right here this guy yeah
I'd like to put that 50,000 sham fer
with the part off tool that I also made
on the opposite side of the hex head
with the turning tool so once I
highlight that I have the option down at
the bottom for nothing a chamfer or a
radius I want a chamfer I want the share
for size to be 50 thousandths and my
angle ad that's this guy right here
where do you want to go from the zero
position to where the champers starts
now it's automatically gonna do a 45 so
let's throw 0 in there and I'll do my
next tool path there you go oh
my little position I don't need any of
these tool path settings so okay let's
do a process test again and see what
happens start it up to turn rough turn
finish
there's my part off and it's sham fir'd
on the backside awesome awesome
but now we're thinking wait a second
charlie we cut off but that thing just
fell in the chips this is what I was
getting to before this process started
that we can now select a new process to
a process edit from the one spindle and
under options I have an opportunity for
transfer by clicking on transfer now
it's gonna say are we going from the
left to the right or the right to the
left in our case it's left to right and
look at this reverse transfer no torque
skip we're just grabbing it so no torque
skip but right here cut off process this
is asking us do you want to tie in a cut
off process to this yeah absolutely I do
so let's do a cut off select there's my
little process tree and there's the
process I just made so click on it boom
now the the software automatically knows
that it's time to bring this sub spindle
over before the cut off process starts
because I said no to torque skip all of
these guys are leave alone we'll do that
at a later date but my transfer start
point and my transfer point let's go -
let's grab this thing by say 2 inches
just to say we did I'm making the W 0
axis the face of the part so the
transfer start point is where the tool
is or where the W is going to wrap it to
and the transfer point is how far is
it's going to come in and then the
transfer F is the feed rate
and the final the W escape point where
do you want to send the W axis once
we're done there we go we're done the
approach and the approach an overshot
distance that's to do with torque limits
so we don't need that at all
we have escaped our turret our a turret
to a position of thirty and thirty a
just get it the heck out of the way
everything else is grayed out okay boom
hey now we just did a cutoff and a
transfer in one shot finally here we are
26 minutes into this video and I still
haven't gotten to what I wanted which
was the the hex process so I'm gonna
pick up the next process I'm gonna do a
process edit now we're on the second
spindle and we're gonna do a multi
machine these are my options I'm going
to do the line and now it's asking me
are you using the full width of the
cutter are you doing a full width cutter
with a mil groove you're doing
contouring that's the one I want right
there or are we doing a chamfer we're
gonna do the contouring now the process
is are you roughing in other words are
you doing a step down with the end mill
are you doing a finish pass are you
doing a width so step over with the end
mill roughing or a finishing pass with
the same strategy in our case we're just
gonna buzz this thing once so I'm gonna
use the line contour finish left face or
side now even though we're working on
the right spindle it still says left
face because we're imagining that hey
this is a second lathe it's on the right
side that really were still speaking to
it as if it were a standard lathe so
this is the first decision that tends to
trip up people when they're gonna do a
hex if I do a left face that means that
my tool is oriented parallel to the z
axis yeah no problem gotcha with that
but here's the problem you cannot
possibly expect the y-axis
walk all the way around the part it's
just not gonna happen you don't have
that kind of travel it is the cleanest
looking tool path but it is you
physically don't have the travel to get
all the way over the X centerline
particularly when the y axis is already
using up a portion of the x axis travel
so we're gonna do both we're gonna start
with the left face and I'm going to show
you some options for it then we're gonna
do a side function but let's do the left
first do I want to use the C axis or the
y axis
well it's hourly just wasted 30 seconds
of my life explaining that Y axis was
simply not going to work if we travel
all the way around the part that's not
to say we can't use the y axis and we're
gonna try it but let's start with the C
axis this is going to we are gonna speak
to the machine in X&Y but it's gonna
respond in X and C which is kind of cool
so this is offset number 2 and tool
number 2 it's a half inch end mill with
eight hundred thousandth of flute length
next cut condition we're gonna leave
everything alone and now I'm gonna go
into next shape now it's showing me the
face of the part because hey I know that
this is what we're working on this is
how we're going to this is how we're
going to be viewing the part make it
easy on us the first question is do you
want to speak to me this is a OT asking
you do you want to speak to me in X c
and z coordinates or XY and z
coordinates if i no radial degrees of my
features this would be the hot ticket
but if I just know x and y coordinate I
can speak to it in XYZ and it will still
respond by moving the C axis so let's do
that ah that one I like a lot better the
reference angle is what do you want to
rotate the part so that you can speak
you can speak easier let's say for
instance I had a flat that was across
the top of the BART here at say 33 and
1/3 degrees and I don't want to have to
do all the math for start point and end
point on that so I could tell it hey I
want you to rotate 90 degrees so that
you're along the Y and then I'm gonna
use the 33 and a third degree or
whatever the heck it is it just makes
life a little easier for you we're not
gonna do that in this case we're gonna
leave it at 0 my start point in X now be
just in a ot is still using the Okuma
format that when you are speaking to me
in mil terms when you're talking y-axis
I want to know radiuses I do not want a
no diametrical standard so yeah you got
to remember that we are a radius radial
dimension here so let's start with our X
dimension I don't know what it is I know
my flat diameter is one point three
seven five but let's divide that by two
so that we get a radial dimension 687 5
cool and I start pointing why I want it
to be up here somewhere so that I can
just make a cut straight down let's go
ahead and give it a dimension of minus
0.6 87 5 itself that should put me
whoops that should be positive 4 in 687
5 way to go Charlie and now our start
point in Z and end point in Z this one
throws a lot of people for a loop and it
doesn't show up until you start trying
to verify or write a program and then
you start getting phantom errors and
it's focusing right on this start point
and end point Z I just want to make one
shot half an inch deep and so my gut
says ok my start point in Z should be
minus 0.5 and my endpoint in Z is also
minus 0.5 no that's not what they're
asking they want to know what is the
clearance plane to which the tool can
retract before it moves on to another
feature so don't make the start point
and end point the same
then you start getting
collision-avoidance and process errors
so let's take this two hundred
thousandth above the part and my
endpoint to minus 0.5 in my offset
direction I'm going to do some climb
cutting here so we'll make it a left
there's my little point right here the
move I want to make to start this is to
go straight down so I'm gonna simply say
face and my end in X should be minus
point 6 87 5 the tangent question here I
always leave blank really they're asking
is the next move going to be tangent to
this line or not I let the process
decide for itself when I click on OK it
shows me the line coming down now here
is where we're gonna make another
decision if I were making a square this
would be a very simple thing for me to
program all three of them all the way
across I'd simply go positive 687 5
positive positive negative negative
negative negative positive positive
positive and that would just take me all
around the square but I want to do a hex
so I cannot that possibly come up with
this point without doing a whole bunch
of math so I do know that this flat is
what I want so I am going to say that's
the end of my feature but I'm going to
tell it now we're gonna do a pattern so
next pattern how many of these are you
gonna make I want to do 6 and make them
60 degrees apart Wow look at how easy
that was and I did not have to compute
these end points and I didn't have to I
didn't have to do anything fancy I'm
done
next toolpath I don't need any
clearances I do have the opportunity for
an approach and escape now I kind of
cheated here half an hour ago I said
that the the numbers we give are when
the tool contacts material but I simply
didn't know where the the contact point
was so I just built in a approach and
escaped but in our case let's do this
just to say we did give it an approach
and escape the approach I could do an
arc or a line let's do a little arc a
radius of one to five and an escape arc
of also a radius of point one to five
there we go okay there it is it just
gave me the approach and escape how
Nikki is that so let's take a look at
what this is going to do process test
I'm going to do a display change and
switch over to the second spindle there
it went I've already moved my view to be
isometric for this one too
and if I now quit out of that and hit
start it's going to run the first
portion of the program but I'm not going
to be able to see it so to make things
easy on man just gonna reach up and
touch the process here that's where I
want to start and click the word start
and look new so what happened here I got
a little alarm nose comp circle one okay
well what I didn't pay attention to was
that my lead in and lead out is smaller
than the size of the tool that is a
problem for me so let's get in here and
change my approach escape to a
oh let's just take it into a line and a
line that'll make life a lot easier for
me sure as heck doesn't need to be that
long let's take it half of the half of
the diameter of the cutter okay there we
go
now let's do another process test just
like I said before display change one to
spindle two and we'll highlight that guy
and now we'll start there we go
now you notice that the software is
showing the tool do exactly what I
explained the my W cannot do it can't
get down here on the X minus side and
make that cut well the software does not
show the part rotating but because we
selected C axis it is moving the the
part around not moving the tool around
tool is still gonna move in the x axis
but it just cut in C axis nice gotcha
alright let's quit out of this and I
want to show you that if we do the
process edit if we do this again let's
go back to the second spindle multi
machine do the line do the contouring
line contour finish left face this time
I'm gonna select the y-axis same tool
too - next cut condition everybody's
good next shape we're speaking in XY and
Z and let's just buzz through this real
quickly we're gonna go - point
oops nope oops that should be positive
687 5 y minus point 687
five star Point C Point 1 and minus
point 5 and it's still a left okay we'll
make that facing move just buzzing
through this as quickly as possible okay
and to oops I made them exactly the same
that's not wise let's get back up here
and do our edit this that should be
positive point 687 5 that will look
better boom there's our feature next
pattern 660 degrees there they all are
I'm not going to do an approach and
escape I'm good with it
okay so now when I do my process test
these two features are going to look
exactly the same
you start at that one this one I know is
in C axis
Jupe Jupe and then the same thing in
y-axis so the graphic looks exactly the
same but in my head I know that the
first operation was utilizing C axis
rotation and the second was using Y axis
and because of the way I made this made
that process it is going to try to over
travel that Y axis so I would have to if
I really wanted to do this utilizing the
y axis along this this stretch which I
know is never going to take the X below
minus 687 5 my process would be to take
out these these patterns make it just 1
and then I would copy this over six
times and utilize the process shape edit
that guy to my reference angle being
sixty degrees first one would be zero
second one would be sixty third one
would be 120 so forth and so on so that
now I know that the material is going to
rotate always maintaining this tool path
with the side of the anvil as we as we
utilize the advantage of y-axis being a
cleaner cut than C axis C axis can cause
a little surface abnormality all that
being said that is not how I would want
to cut this flat I personally would
prefer to use the end of the end mill so
let's do that real quick before I lose
everybody's attention shoot shooting for
a new process will process edit to
spindle multi machine we're gonna do a
line again contouring line finish all
that's the same but now we're gonna use
the side of the part I don't have a
toolset for this so let's just do a
quick five and my tool will be three
inches long it'll be a half inch
diameter end mill and it'll have four
flutes
there's my tool my cut conditions I'll
leave alone and now my shape notice it's
got a nice little compass rose down here
to help me with what I'm doing so if
there's my reference angle we're gonna
start at zero my start point in X
remember we talked about how the the X
or on the previous cut the start point
and end point and Z needed to be
different
well now we're working on the side so
the start point in X needs to be
something greater than the end point in
X so I'm gonna start with this guy and
my end point in X is going to be six
eighty seven five and my start point
let's give it the clearance of say
one inch start point and wide let's make
that the same 687 5 that we had
previously and my start point in Z is
well yeah that's gonna be how far into
the part let's go - the radius of the
cutter so now we'll have a full cutter
width and because I chose that Z I'm not
using any cutter cop I'm using the
center of the tool okay there's my start
point let's just make a facing move down
to Y minus 0.6 87 5 there it is so now
let's say next pattern we're gonna do
six of those at 60 degrees apart tool
path I don't need to approach an escape
I'm done let's see what happens when I
process test and pick only that process
I've got to do my one spindle to spindle
select the process and start through
how's that for styling this is exactly
how I prefer to cut a hex if it's small
enough and I have enough why travel to
do that this is ideal plus the the
x-axis live tools generally they sound a
little better than the z-axis live tools
and yeah I like stuff to sound good
alright one last thing I wanted to do
before I split off for Thanksgiving
dinner we're gonna come in here and
we're gonna do some holes on those hexes
let's do a process edit this is on the
two spindle multi machine this time
we're doing holes we're going to drill
in our case let's start by centering on
the side and this is asking see axis or
y axis in our case I just want to have
some holes that are radiating through
the center of the bowl so it really
doesn't matter which one is C axis we're
gonna do a tool setting while let's just
say this is tool number six and it is a
ninety degree spot and it's so let's say
it's a 3/16 cool cut conditions I'm
gonna leave it alone
too late first thing I want to do is
specify whether I am using the point of
the tool as depth or the effective
length in this case let's just use the
tool point my clearance how far up above
the part do you want to go to start
that's a little light start point in X
where are we up here so you notice that
we are in a radial dimension here or are
we in diameter hmm let's find out I'm
gonna put in the one point three seven
five from a diametrical viewpoint start
point in C minus 0.25 right in the
center of the flat my end point in X
let's make it one point 365
making a total of five thousands so by
looking at that tent ow it's 5,000 so
yep we're speaking in a diametrical
value so let's take this down to 1.3 25
let's make that pretty heavy and that's
my first hole my next is a pattern I can
either do an arc a line or free position
it doesn't really matter what the heck I
do here in my case let's do an arc and
we're going to do six of them clockwise
60 degrees apart toolpath okie dokie
there they are let's take a look at our
process and see what happens if I do my
one two spindle change quit out of that
let's start with that guy so that we see
the end mill
Oh what the heck happened there that did
not look right let's go back and take a
look at our process cut condition shape
see what we did wrong depth went to five
clearance point one that's from the
start of the whole pattern sixty degrees
clockwise
[Music]
oh there's my problem sixty degrees
that's asking for my endpoint angle so
it just tried to put six holes sixty
degrees apart yeah all of us make
mistakes don't we the endpoint angle
should be 360 there that looks a little
better let's take a look at the process
now see what happens when we one spindle
two spindle let's pick that guy up start
him mill mill mill mill boom spotting
looks good okay one last thing that we
want to do let's do our two spindle
multi machine hole drilling we're gonna
drill let's just go blind this time
we're gonna do a side hole in C axis
let's give it to number seven by seven
0.125 let's make this a two inch long
drill whoops
two Langille should be 118 and the drill
diameter should be 125 all right next
cut condition the reason that I wanted
to do this instead of just telling you
hey duplicate the spotting cycle but
this time tell it to go all the way
through it's because there's a couple of
things on here I wanted to point out the
pecking on and off you can just drill or
you can Peck but this positioning kind
of messes with people this is an option
that Okuma throws into the software it
gives you the opportunity to spot the
hole with the same tool you're going to
drill with doesn't make a lot of sense
when you first think of it but basically
what they're doing is saying hey I am
willing to use this tool at a different
feed and speed to make a dimple on the
part and then shift my feeds and speeds
to drilling capacity and finish the hole
in our case if we did want to do the
positioning which we we don't we already
spotted the hole
but if we did I could say exist and now
these guys down at the bottom are the
modified feed and speed for the spotting
cycle in our case we're gonna say none
it grazed them out automatically there's
our feeds and speeds same sort of thing
has that part off tool we dealt with
half an hour ago now we're gonna do our
shape let's do the exact same process
that we did before so shape copy
there's my military Center execute it
automatically populates all of my guys
right here except for the depth because
it knows hey this was a spot obviously
the drill is gonna be different let's
take that all the way to zero so now
these these holes should be intersecting
with the center of the part endpoint
angle not going to make that mistake
again
tool path okay and now let's do the
process test and I want to run the first
few tools we already saw there's turn
turn turn
finish sub spindle grabs parts off and
now we're going to go over to the second
spindle and watch the c-axis
milling of flats and then we'll watch
the end milling of flats
spotting the hole drilling the holes and
we're done
now we could just go on and count our
money all right I hope this helps you
out if you have any questions feel free
to leave them in the comment section if
you have an idea for a video you'd like
to see do the same thing because we're
always here to help you can also reach
out to your local Gosselaar application
staff and we'll be happy to answer any
questions we can thanks for watching